i
[Música]
a
la epidemia de kobe 19 retoma poco a
poco fuerza en francia con una
particularidad la tasa de incidencia de
esto es el número de casos por cada
100.000 habitantes está haciendo mayor
en el grupo de jóvenes entre 15 y 44
años de edad según el último informe del
20 de agosto esa tasa en ese grupo
etario corresponde a un 43 1% pero
además del número total de casos un 48%
lo representan jóvenes de 15 a 44 años
de edad y no sólo eso en los últimos
contagios de kobe en francia un 80 por
ciento son asintomáticos y de esas
personas que no presentan signos del coi
19 un 60 por ciento tienen entre 15 y 44
años de edad por lo mismo el ministro de
la salud ha llamado a los jóvenes a usar
mascarillas a respetar las medidas de
distancia social porque si bien a lo
mejor ellos no desarrollan la enfermedad
de manera grave pueden contagiar a
personas mayores de su entorno y además
se ha visto que los contagios se están
dando sobre todo en las empresas en el
entorno familiar y en los eventos
[Música]
pues bélgica se encuentra conmocionada
tras confirmarse la muerte de una joven
de apenas 20 años diagnosticada con kobe
19 aunque la muerte no es habitual en
este grupo de edad esta noticia coincide
con un alza importante en los casos
confirmados en menores de 30 años de los
12 mil casos de kobe 19 registrados en
bélgica en el último mes la mayoría
correspondían a personas de entre 19 y
29 años según los datos del instituto
belga de la salud y esto preocupa
particularmente porque en septiembre se
prevé la vuelta a las clases y aunque se
hará con muchas medidas de seguridad
también se trata de volver poco a poco a
la normalidad eso sí los casos en
personas de mediana edad y mayores de 65
años se encuentran estabilizados aunque
la media de edad también acá en los
hospitales mientras que durante el pico
de la pandemia entre marzo y junio de
este año la mitad de los casos
registrados en hospitales estaban por
encima de los 75 años la mitad de las
personas hospitalizadas actualmente
están por debajo de los 65
[Música]
en las últimas semanas en el reino unido
ha aumentado el número de contagios en
adultos jóvenes en particular en
personas entre los 20 y 29 años de edad
la autoridad de salud pública de
inglaterra informó que de los nuevos
casos de coronavirus en las últimas
semanas 25% son en personas menores de
30 años mientras que el grupo más
afectado es en hombres menores de 40
años el riesgo de la población
vulnerable mayor de 70 años ha
disminuido durante esta pandemia la tasa
de mortalidad en la población joven
también es mucho más baja y únicamente
93 personas han muerto durante esta
pandemia en el reino unido- los expertos
en salud aseguran que el número de
contagios va en aumento entre los
adultos jóvenes debido a que muchos
prefieren ignorar el distanciamiento
social además de que ha habido un
relajamiento
las restricciones y un regreso a los
puestos de trabajo
[Música]